There are so many new beauty releases
happening all the time, so we gathered
some of the most-hyped
products from November
to test for ourselves.
Let's start with the brand
everyone is talking about,
Ariana Grande's REM Beauty.
I don't have every product,
but I have a decent batch.
Now, I love miss ponytail,
and I will buy anything she tells me to,
but we definitely have some products here
that are underwhelming.
The skips for me are
the volumizing mascara
and the eyeliner.
The mascara was pretty clumpy,
and I've tried better mascara formulas
at the drugstore.
The eyeliner also wasn't
great, which is shocking,
because I feel like that's her thing.
It was just skipping on the eye,
and it wasn't as intensely black
as I wanted it to be.
Everything else I tried I loved.
The lip products are very pigmented
and comfortable on the lips.
The plumping gloss has this
really nice minty scent,
and the lipstick smells like vanilla cake.
I love it.
Also, I know everyone hated the packaging,
but come on, this lipstick is so cute.
It looks like a little astronaut!
The liquid shadow was super easy to blend
and looked pretty on the eyes.
I will say, I wish it was more sparkly.
It looked a little dull for me.
If you can only get one product
from this brand, though,
get the highlighter topper.
It's more on the metallic side,
but not glittery at all,
and it looks amazing on the skin.
I freaked out when I saw that ELF came out
with basically their own version
of the ABH Brow Freeze.
I still love that fluffy,
laminated brow look,
so of course I had to get it
and compare the two.
Mine did come super
cloudy and white-looking.
On the website, the product
looks totally clear,
just like the ABH Brow Freeze,
so I don't know what that's about.
Anyway, I applied the ELF
Brow Lift on my right brow
using the specific Brow Lift Applicator
they released with it, and already,
I could tell that this is
the same as the Brow Freeze,
or at least as close as you can get.
It didn't take a lot of product
to get the brow looking full and fluffy,
and I also love the applicator,
because it came with this
little flat piece at the end
to really press the brow hairs into place.
I used the ABH Brow
Freeze on my left brow,
so you can see how similar the effect is.
I highly, highly, highly recommend this
if you're into this kind of brow look.
I was so confused when I saw this
petri-dish-looking
highlighter all over TikTok.
This is the Huda Beauty Rose Quartz
Face Gloss Highlighting
Dew, and it's essentially
a cream highlighter-face gloss hybrid.
I've never been interested
in these kinds of products,
because they tend to remove foundation,
and that's pretty much
what happened with this.
The formula is almost tacky.
It's very sticky.
So everywhere I applied it,
it was lifting off more
and more foundation.
The glow it gives is actually pretty nice,
but it's not worth the trouble for me.
I'd rather just use a powder highlighter.
Purple blush has been everywhere lately,
and I've been wanting to try it so bad.
This is one of the purple
blushes I kept seeing,
the Made by Mitchell Blursh.
I'm not saying that weird,
that's what it's called.
I was playing with fire
applying a liquid blush
over my already powdered base,
a purple blush nonetheless,
but I did it anyway,
and this formula actually blew my mind.
It didn't remove any foundation,
it didn't get patchy,
and it was so effortless to blend out.
I don't know if I'm super sold
on purple blush on my skin tone.
I just don't think that
it's more flattering
than my normal peachy-orange blushes,
but it's still pretty.
I definitely want more
blushes from this brand.
I was so intrigued by this concealer,
because it's described
as a concealer serum,
which I've never tried before.
When I was applying it with my brush,
I was getting excited
because it seemed like
the coverage was great.
It was super creamy.
But then I started blending.
On the rest of my face,
it blended out just fine
and I thought it looked good,
but something weird was
happening on my under-eyes,
specifically on my right side.
The product started to pill up
and get kind of weird,
but it didn't do that on my left side,
so I'm confused.
I think it all looked better
after I set it with
powder, finished my makeup,
and applied my setting spray.
But I'm not a huge fan
of this concealer yet.
Maybe I just have to try it again
with a different foundation.
I am so not a glitter person,
but I saw some videos
of this particular glitter in action
and fell in love.
This is the LA Girl
Glitterholic Glitter Topper
in Holo-Glam.
Oh, my God, say that five times fast.
It has this color-shifting magic in it
that makes it look like you
have nothing on your eyes,
but then you move your head
and it's, like, purple, and then blue.
I don't even know how to describe it,
but I'm really obsessed.
It has a built-in base,
so you don't need to use
any glitter adhesive.
Just apply it with your fingers.
I think I would still use
this with a glitter base
just for some extra security,
but I'm paranoid.
I love this, and it's only 6 bucks.